[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with director of the John Smith Center
at the University of Glasgow Kezia
dugdale and former number 10
speechwriter ASA Bennett so let's see
what's on some of those front pages for
you now
well the sacking of Nadeem zahar we as
conservative party chairman over his tax
Affairs makes the front of the Metro
with the headline he's NAD sorry at all
the mirror also leads with Nadeem
zahawi's sacking
sunac sax Tory party chair takes the
front of the financial times as the
paper highlights of zahawi's serious
breach of Minister's code
the time says Rishi sunax got tough on
standards as he sacks Mr zahawi as Tory
party chairman
this story also makes the front of the
eye with allies of the Prime Minister
allegedly blaming a former leader Boris
Johnson for a so-called sleaze Legacy
while the telegraph says allies of Mr
zahawi are claiming he was sacked
without a fair hearing
The Daily Express leads with a
revelation from Boris Johnson that
Russia's Vladimir Putin threatened him
during a phone call after he visited
Ukraine's Capital last February
it's also the lead in The Daily Mail
with the headline Putin's threat to kill
Boris
while the Daily Star splashes were the
story about Pamela Anderson and her
initial Ambitions to become a librarian
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
kezi dagdale and ASA Bennett welcome to
both of you let's start with the Metro
and uh their headline I'm not sure it's
it's particularly clever actually he's
NAD sorry at all referring to the fact
that Nadeem zahawi hasn't actually
apologized Kezia
yes so this has been a story running all
day starting about two minutes to nine
this morning when purchasing like the
Prime Minister formally sacked Nadeem
sahawi after he had received the report
from the ethics investigation into his
tax Affairs that put Michael Gove on the
spot first thing today reacting to that
live on the TV news across the day and
it took until well into this afternoon
for uh the minister or the former
minister to really offer his own reply
to the situation he spends the first few
paragraphs of this letter in response to
the Prime Minister sacking and outlining
his successes and government officer
practice we quite often see ministers
undertake whenever they've been relieved
of that office and then the closing
paragraph has a real job at the media
suggesting that they were really quite
underhand and have not played Fair
nothing in this letter represents any
sort of apology for and the reason that
he's lost his job which is his inability
in the words of the ethics commissioner
to be open honest accountable and to
demonstrate leadership when it came to
is tax affairs
Acer the article is describing Nadine
zahabi as unrepentant saying that he's
refused to say sorry after being fired
um do you think he does come across as
Unapologetic
I think self-evidently because he in
short would believe that he can of
course be Unapologetic because he
doesn't believe he has anything to
apologize for because I think it boiled
down his defense effectively has been
that he's been very much a successful
businessman an entrepreneur making many
millions and so obviously you know
there's been a very complicated
backstory with his tax Affairs and he
has a dialogue of hmrc
um it clearly there's a subtlety where
well as come up in the ethics inquiry
where the Solari Magnus the prime
minister's ethics advisor suggested that
he should have been aware with hmrc were
wanting to talk to him that it was
actually a formal investigation that it
was something that he should probably
start disclosing to people whereas uh
Mrs zahari makes out that he just
thought it was answering inquiries from
hmrc
um in the meantime there's a side class
of course when journalists have been
trying to talk about this in advance uh
he's been very litigious or threatening
all sorts you know to come down on
various reporters asking questions like
a ton of bricks so I think it's all this
this is the culmination of a due process
which the Prime Minister has been
overseeing in which you know there were
critics suggesting he should have gone
in faster and he has sacked him
summarily days ago but I think it's that
the Prime Minister wants to have this
play out so that he could try and say
that the process was behind him it was
justified it was transparent it was
clear because it was a frankly very
damning letter from the ethics advisor
you know the final now on the coffin but
the trouble is is that Mr sorry clearly
does not agree and he would still wants
to fight on his he was not groveling in
his letter he did not apologize you know
he clearly wants to have his you know
have his case and he will still press it
and Casey when we look at the the
financial times that their simple
headline at cynax sax Tory party chairs
zahawi over a serious breach of
ministers code is the the Prime Minister
found wanting in this this whole um
scenario in that he didn't sack him
sooner
um and he did say in Parliament that all
questions had been answered
the band strikes right at the heart of
the debate that the conservative party
will now have about what this says about
Rishi sinach's leadership more generally
in truth though we should remember that
for much of the time Boris Johnson was
prime minister of the ethics post laid
vacant and Richie sunak in his first 100
days in office did appoint 72 that that
person was Lori Magnus and it's Lori
Magnus who has over the space of less
than seven days conducted this
investigation and provided a conclusion
and as the financial times describes
here it is a serious breach of the
Mysterio code in fact it is three
separate breaches connected to the hmrc
investigation he says one there is a
cover-up that the investigation was ever
taking place in the first place two
there was a cover-up of the findings of
that hmrc investigation and thirdly the
cabinet secretary had
um not explained himself when asked you
by the media he made a series of untrue
statements as a consequence of those
investigations so that was three strikes
and you're out serious speech of The
Minister's code he's got to go so I
think Richie sunak was very clear he had
put that advisor in place there was a
process to be followed and he would
respond once the outcome of that process
had concluded that's exactly what's
happened it's exactly what he's done so
one side of the conservative Camp can
certainly see that he's ruthless there's
quite clearly some detractors within the
party who would like to have seen it
handled differently and perhaps we'd
rather see Nadine still in this job
tonight hey so would it have been
handled better if the the Prime Minister
had perhaps suspended Nadeem zahawi
while investigations were ongoing
that's a really interesting question
um I think it's something no doubt
they'll be discussing amongst the team
about how they can show they can go
faster in these things in the future
because this as we know in politics
either this will not be the only
controversy you know Mrs Sudan will have
to deal with
um particularly that's remember you know
almost that that blinking you miss at
the moment where I think it's about the
first two weeks we had sir Gavin
Williamson government and here just a
step aside because of all sorts of
allegations about his conduct
um I think it's a way for the alleged
bullying you know whether it is previous
experience in governments which is Led
back into the cabinet office
um so I think it's something where you
know would like to think now that if
integrity was a watchword in this
Administration that he's at least
putting any miscreants on notice
and Casey you were saying before that
actually in Nadine was appointed
initially by Boris Johnson VI is
suggesting that uh sunax allies are
blaming Boris Johnson and Tori sleaze um
for Nadeem zahawi's uh situation
is that a long stretch
yeah I'm not sure I mean I think if you
were around the Prime Minister advising
him working day in day night you'd be
really frustrated at the number of these
stories which you've inherited from the
last Administration which are now
plaguing yours so Thursday of this week
will actually mark 100 days of British
Scenic in office he can be pleased that
he's outlived less trust in terms of his
tenure but can he really point to that
much else he's achieved in that period I
think most observers of politics would
say that that list is quite limited and
they would also offer an excuse list and
that excuse list would be that list of
problems he's inherited everything to do
with Dominic Rabb in the alleged
building that he's accused of as well
the braverman's provided a series of
negative headlines and there's questions
over her conduct all of these people
have been issues and problems for the
party prior to his appointment so it's
no wonder really that sunax allies feel
a little aggrieved like they can't get
on the front foot because of what they
inherited from the last Administration
and indeed the one before yeah the eye
is saying that MPS are saying the Legacy
Boris Johnson's time in power encouraged
Tory chairman to try to cling on um do
you agree with that analysis Asa
well I've heard really compelling
actually is the bullet point for a few
uh points further down that says the
Tory members went polled there's more of
them that attempted to have Boris back
then uh you know right those who would
say you know moving on and would reject
the idea of a Boris comeback so I think
it's maybe that they they have a
slightly Rose tinted view of that idea
because he he was a lot of people
remember Boris sent us this kind of uh
you know Herculean mayor of London
popular and beloved by all but you know
in the latter stage of his Premiership
he was starting to be a drain and a
negative on the Tory poll ratings it was
the start I think if memory serves where
the party was slipping to about Five
Points behind labor and now of course
it's a real Hemorrhage where it's 20
points and so this is why I think he
really sense that anger and you know
suit neck and his team because and the
frustration because they had the
briefing last week with their election
strategist Isaac levito and effectively
said that you know it is still winnable
this is the next election but
effectively everything has to go right
they cannot afford any more mistakes and
so that's why you have this Legacy
issues creeping over the personalities
who've been you know had the slings and
arrows like this you know really biting
the party dragging sunac down then you
know this starts to be a reels of danger
to the long-term polling prospects and
Kelsey how much damage do you think has
been done to the the government and to
the Prime Minister which is unac in
particular that the mirror headline
um embold capitals rotten to the core it
says
yes and this is a double page spread in
the mirror here no doubt they're
enjoying this particular story it's just
not a huge amount more detail in this
story though there's a a source a Tory
MP Source the um says that Rishi sunak
was supposed to be the new broom that he
was going to come in and wipe the Slate
cleaved and allow the parties to rebuild
ahead of the next general election it is
actually the quoted Michael Portillo
that describes the Prime Minister as
weak is looking indecisive and and
therefore damaged as a consequence of
the story and then there's your usual
pity remark from uh Lee Anderson the
Tory MP I think from Ashfield who says
that the current conservative government
are acting like the band and the Titanic
that's come from a private WhatsApp
message group so you're starting to get
some murmurs in the conservative party
that they are unhappy that they're Fed
Up of the story dominating the news and
they're starting to speak out and break
the discipline and that is required
really to allow the government to get
onto the issues that it's talking about
I don't think this is hugely damaging
and for a Rishi spoon act because it
looked looks like a story that he's
inherited from others he looks like he's
taking the right steps around following
due process appointing the Essex advisor
and I also think there's something about
setting a precedent here the next time
there's a big Scandal around a minister
and you've got to anticipate that there
will be looking at the history of what's
happened over the past couple of years
he can follow that process again he can
defer to the ethics advisor he knows
he's likely to get a quick response and
then when he acts on the results of that
investigation he'll be doing it in
conclusion to a piece of independent
investigation not to do it as a response
to political scores he's got that
distance between himself and the party
now by deferring to that ethics advisor
so we met in time if this party allowed
him to come out of the Scandal Just a
Little Bit Stronger okay Kezia and ASA
for the moment thank you we are going to
take a break but coming up this story on
the front of the Daily Express their
headline Boris Putin told me I could
kill you in a minute stay with us for
much more
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview is still with me Kezia dugdale
and Acer Bennett there they both are
let's have a look at the Telegraph and
and this story which suggests that
they're perhaps even more worrying
figures about uh the any wait times the
true a e wait times the NHS is going to
be ordered to reveal them
um that's that's worrying in itself
isn't it Acer
absolutely but I think this shows the
Department of Health is really gripping
the scale of the challenge because they
know you have to get these figures out
the transparency is often the strongest
driver to take action and so if this
really lights a fire under the feet of
NHS bosses you know there's more power
there elbow but at the same time it's
not just trying to sort of use data to
power the change it's also a really sort
of strong you know sense of mission here
from the health secretary and that he
writes about the idea of breaking the
cycle of winter crisis which I know many
viewers will sympathize with because
we've all been astonished by what's been
happening over the last few weeks and
the previous years of course where it
seems it's almost systemic that there
will be problems that winter are real
crunch points um of course the last few
weeks have had even more so the
pressures were given the you know flu
strap a and um an outbreak of I believe
it was a yes all sorts of industrial
strike action
um and so as a result there has to be
that sense of change and you you then
have something else that's very
interesting I'll quickly mentioned
finally
um there's also work going on about you
know having virtual Wards so that
patients could be you know sort of
diagnosed dealt with more at home so
trying to sort of more creatively use
technology to help find that
efficiencies as well and to free up beds
so people are not having to you know add
more to the backlog that they have to
work through yes the time between
attending a e and being admitted uh
shouldn't be longer than 12 hours and
that figure reached 55 000 in December
but the number could be five times as
high Kezia
yes and that's why there's this call for
a greater transparency from the English
Health sector and this is of course a
story that just applies in England there
are different mechanisms around the
statistics and different publishing
patterns in Scotland and I'm sure the
same as the case in Wales but the
reality here is that those 55 000 people
waited more than 12 hours in December
but that figure as you've described only
counts those at the point of their
admission so they were admitted to
hospital and then still had to wait 12
hours for treatment what about all those
people who were waiting to see somebody
in the first instance that's the
transparency that we're looking for here
so we can see the extent of the problem
and hope that the additional resources
the prime minister is allocating here
for the NHS in England those additional
800 ambulances and the more beds that
he's promised will make some sort of
Dent into this particular problem prime
minister's given themselves two years to
make real progress here to be able to
demonstrate that things are getting
better his NHS recovery plan is set to
last that long you've got to think
that's leading towards the next general
election you want some proof points by
the time that comes around yes about
establishing that the problem is halfway
to to dealing with it to the express
Acer and Boris Johnson claiming that
Vladimir Putin made a terrible threat to
him
yes this is uh for a documentary to Mark
the anniversary of the invasion of
Ukraine and um as part of this you know
Boris who was then the Prime Minister
when this it all kicked off it was in
revealing lifting the lid on a long
conversation he had with the Russian
president ahead of the invasion
um in which clearly a very sort of
living up to the kind of pseudo-bond
villain or are these various Russian
humor and the dark Gallows human sense
uh Mia Putin is trying to almost suggest
a joke about how easy it could be to
sort of bump him off and so you have to
be very careful about that yeah it's
definitely very Macabre but even then
what we've seen since is many times more
you know ghoulish from Jews of Putin's
orders and what he's provoked now as we
see going on every day in Ukraine
because they're the actual quote is I
don't want to hurt you but with a
missile it would only take a minute
yes I mean maybe I'm getting cynical in
my old age usually but I find it quite
astonishing that both the Daily Express
and the Daily Mail choose to run the
story when every other paper is writing
up stories about how weak the prime
minister is that Synergy between those
being one side of the story and then a
story of strength about Boris Johnson
and him staring into the whites of the
eyes of Vladimir Putin is just a bit
much for my liking the timing seems a
bit sort of opposite in that sense but
yes it's the strong bond language here
about Putin saying to him I could have a
missile here in a minute and that would
be you gone and Boris Johnson in replies
saying if you were to attack Ukraine
then you can expect NATO to respond very
aggressively this sort of like bang of
the fists and that tension between these
two leaders will make for an excellent
documentary but the timing to me is
highly suspicious
cynic there um because yeah let's move
on to the final story just got time for
for this story in the times world and um
an American General is saying that
they're the possible ability of War
with China by 2025 it is highly likely
Acer
well
um President Biden has said that they're
watching out we've seen Nancy Pelosi go
to visit Taiwan so this is the next sort
of Step Up in the the generals and the
among the Air Force for example are
saying they are you're ready if all
everything sort of kicks off there
because I think it's that
it's a memo that's leaked obviously
questions may all be asked whether it's
been deliberate should we say to you
know because it's all very consistent
with what the US wants Beijing to know
beijing's naturally reacted as hackles
are up and so I think what we need to
know basically is over the next few
years geopolitics is back we're going to
see clearly tensions and all sorts of
bricksmanship happening over
um The Straits of Taiwan yes this
General uh Mike minnehan he's in the
memo has actually told operational
commanders to make ready for combat um
it's more than an inkling it seems Kezia
yes and a couple of years ago we might
have had stories like this but it would
have been uh you know somebody from the
forces in the in the U.S Being overheard
or been recorded on a microphone that
perhaps shouldn't have been and then you
would see the US kind of step back from
those remarks seek to clarify them to
dampen down tensions this is quite the
opposite of that it's a memo in which
NBC News have got hold of and as asa's
just said there the president of the
United States is leaning into the story
and saying well actually yes if they
were to do something in the event of
Taiwan in the presidential elections
that are due in Taiwan America would see
that as a reason to bring Force to
action so a real increase in the in the
rhetoric at around
to say there might be a war is really
quite something indeed Kezia and Acer
for the moment uh thank you we'll see
you in the next hour let's take a look
at the weather pointer